avec 2000 entrées vendues en un jour et
demi soit trois salles complètes au Méga
CGR centre et 4atre haut de Lyon la
promo de disco semble bien lancée le
public tourangejo était impatient de
découvrir le film en avant-première et
surtout de rencontrer Franck du Bosque
en personne bah oui ouais quand même bah
oui on s'est fait belle pour
lui la venue de fr du boss moi c'est
c'est le caris c'est personnage je suis
là un peu par hasard parce que c'est mon
fils qui devait venir il a une
impossibilité et donc bon on est venu à
sa place on est des mamis mais on se met
toutes les sauces ça nous va bien le
meneur des bikings non non non et non on
a 40 ballet la fière du samedi soir
c'est fini non je peux pas c'est
impossible tu crois pas qu'on est un peu
rouillé non sous les flash les ovations
et les cris d'amour l'humoriste et le
réalisateur Fabien antegenteé font une
entrée des plus remarqué c'est vrai que
moi j'ai pas joué là depuis 2 ans euh
sur scène je recommence là bientôt à
partir du 3 mai et je serai chez vous
m'a dit on m'a dit le 18 octobre euh
donc forcément c'est un avant-goût euh
terrible quoi c'est cette quand on
arrive et que les gens cri ah j'ai hâte
de direevenenir j'ai hâte de me
retrouver sur scène donc je viens voler
un petit peu de ça dans les
avant-premières je viens goûter un petit
peu le le public et ça fait bien plaisir
ouis une côte de popularité qu'ils ont
acquis notamment grâce au succès de
camping cette fois-ci avec disco on
change de décor mais l'humour reste le
même Jésus
les pour pour camping c'était la
parenthèse des vacances ce moment qu'on
attend tous mais tout au long de l'année
le moment qu'on attend tous c'est le
samedi soir parce qu'on on se dit tiens
on va pouvoir s'amuser s'éclater
rencontrer des filles rencontrer des
hommes et cetera se faire beau ou belle
mettre ses belles tenues pour être un
prince ou une princesse sur le dance
Flor par entre ou avec un kebab auon
choix prochaine avant-première prévu le
mardi 1er avril mais cette fois sans la
présence des
stars